alright guys why don't we get going so
my name is Sean skully
I'm with Daddo today I'm gonna talk to
you about production and what what
production means for machine learning
applications super excited to be here
talking to you guys so what does
production in general mean I was
actually surprised there's there's not a
very common definition online for even
general code in production but I like
this one which the core piece here is
that production code is code that's
being used by the intended audience in a
real-world situation so today we're
going to talk about the different ways
that you use machine learning code in
production for a real audience in the
real world and what factors matter for
machine learning services who-knows-who
dado is awesome about half of you who
went to Brian or Rashad stalk last
couple days cool so you know that
general gist dado we were originally
called graphlab we were an academic
project about eight years ago eight
years in the making and we've been a
company for about two and a half years
we're up in Seattle we're a team of
about 45 or so about half of us are PhDs
and machine learning statistics
distributed systems and the other half
of us have built real-world machine
learning applications for a real
audience and deployed to production for
various things and we're excited about
building tools that make it easier for
other geeks like us to build
applications we've been selling our
stuff since the beginning of the year
these are some of the customers that are
willing to let us say they're using us
in production ok and I'm not going to
give you a big marketing spiel today but
in general people like our stuff because
it makes them more productive so machine
learning in production there's really
kind of two ways applications end up
affecting business or affecting people's
experience
in production and they're two very
different ones so the first one here is
what we'll call batch materialization or
sometimes it's just called batch
production so in this case there's two
examples here one is from Chora and one
is from LivingSocial both of these are
emails that get sent to me on a daily
basis and so if you think about what's
running behind the scenes they're
basically each day some sort of data
pipeline crunches some stuff and then a
ranked set of things is is written to a
database and then that database is
turned into an email a quarries turned
into an email and that email sent to me
and basically nothing happens in between
those two sends so it's just a daily
batch job that gets run and sent so
that's one example and in principle you
know the machine learning here is is
personalizing this email so this is
generally a case used for kind of all
email targeting and apparently I'm
really interested in what it feels like
to be fired from Google I don't work at
Google I've never worked at Google okay
so what's another example this is sort
of the other kind of machine learning in
production and this is called a
real-time service and for this I'm
actually going to create let's use one
so one of the first real time services
that we've used some experienced is
online recommendation systems from
someone like Amazon and so if I go here
in real time it's remembering this let's
let's get rid of this all right oh you
can't see okay it's good it's worthless
give me one second and I'll show you
okay displays
okay and you can see this good so if I
go to Amazon everything I do is watched
and let's say so right now if I go down
here I have no recently viewed items and
there's no recommendations for me if I
click on something let's say this camera
so now when I go down here let's see
yeah when I go down here I viewed this
so your recently viewed items and
featured recommendations so I viewed
this camera and now it's giving me
real-time recommendations that are
related to that thing that I just viewed
and in this case it's all things camera
because this is the only thing that's
known about me if I click on other
things these things will change and so
let's say that I am a videogame freak
and I can't wait for a halo 5 if I click
on this I go back to my recommendations
and now I see that this is dominated by
video games so that's a different kind
of machine learning application that's
in production which is one that's live
and responding to my interactions live
so we're gonna talk about both of those
but focus on the latter so for both of
these both of these involved what I'll
call a model pipeline sometimes called a
data pipeline and so this is connecting
the initial data in the case of the
Korra example this was basically all of
my interaction with various pieces of
content on Korra all the texts the
documents in the case of Amazon this was
just a simple click log what did I
interact with so I take in that data in
whatever form it is I bring it in to
someplace that I can manipulate it
generally I'm going through some sort of
set of transformations and then
ultimately I'm doing some modeling and
if I'm lucky that modeling gets deployed
in one of two ways and these are the two
ways that we saw so in one case I could
take my model deploy it as a service so
that
that service can interact with something
like a user's behavior on a website and
the other case I generate predictions or
a ranked list of things and that ranked
list of things gets written to a
database so this is called a model
pipeline and for the second case what
we're really looking at is a service so
if I take a model and deploy it as a
service whether it's a new experience
like product recommendations or a
machine the machine service like fraud
detection the idea is I have a low
latency rest service that's waiting for
an input and then returns some sort of
prediction back and there's a bunch of
different examples here I'm not going to
go through all of them but product
recommendations was one that we looked
at a really fun one is for online gaming
they have an application called micro
churn most all gaming companies use this
and the goal of this application is to
maximize your time in the game and so
what it does is it watches every little
every little move you make in the game
and then dynamically Tunes the
difficulty of the game to keep you
maximally engaged so what it's doing is
it's waiting it's it's looking every its
of order seconds so every 1 to 10
seconds it's making a prediction of how
likely you are to leave in the next
minute and then dynamically tuning so
that's a very different kind of
real-time application so how do you go
from that model pipeline to a real-time
application what are all the pieces
involved we call this the intelligent
application cycle so here's the model
pipeline which goes from data to a train
model and then for a real-time service
ultimately you're trying to interact
with some sort of other application or
service and that means that you need an
interface here these are typically rest
interfaces you just work pretty well and
then once you have something deployed
typically you're looking at how does
this thing work in production are my
users responding in the way that I
expect are the click-through rates move
the way that I expect and if not I want
to change something so I want to monitor
those things live and then production
usually is about retraining these just
like Cora or LivingSocial you get new
data each day you want to rear ank you
have new data new items new things to
respond to and so you need to retrain
those models and then finally in most
places I have super awesome data science
teams that are working on the next great
feature or model that's gonna also get
deployed and for that once I deploy
those and I want to monitor you know
Model A versus model B or maybe I want
to launch a series of models all
together and let the best one win so
these are all things that you care about
in managing that whole in the end
lifecycle okay so what are some of the
challenges in in running some of these
things in production the first is just
that I have we all have time constraints
whether it's the time to develop
something or the case for these
applications we have a bunch of steps
that need to run fast enough very simple
the second is that the world's
constantly changing whatever data I use
to train my models as soon as I've
trained my model the world's changed and
the models out-of-date and so you need
to be able to quickly respond and adapt
to changing data unfortunately we have
to play well with others and that that
basically means other systems so there's
a classic problem that everyone sees if
you have data science team that works in
R and then a production application
let's say that's written in Java how do
you get these guys to talk to each other
both in terms of people and in terms of
systems and and then it's also the case
in many companies that when I go to
production when my new feature models in
production it means that I'm handing it
off it often means that they need to
understand whatever I did so this is
very very similar to any kind of code
that's pushed to production
for demanding it well for any
application really the other requirement
is it needs to be robust it has to just
work you have to be able to walk away
and have your application continue to
work well without you babysitting it and
then the last one I'm not going to talk
so much about this today but it's really
important one
it's that live machine learning doesn't
always match up with your offline
predictions so has anyone had the
experience of training models offline
thinking that you're gonna have this
huge lift in your in your advertising
strategy or click-through rates and
reality doesn't match up and that's
that's a big problem which often comes
down to what what metrics are right
offline to map to your online setting
it's not always obvious so we're gonna
focus on these other ones today so
what's it what kind of time constraints
matter how do you think about that how
do you deal with the fact that data is
constantly changing so when people talk
about real-time machine learning what
they really mean what do you really need
in those contexts what's important to
play well with others and then finally
what do large-scale services what are
the requirements to make these robust
okay so responsive so at the end of the
day we when we when we make these kinds
of that's funny it's not showing up here
when we make these kinds of services
there's a few key ingredients to make
them awesome the first is that they're
responsive so when I'm on a site I click
something I get a response back really
fast the second is that they're adaptive
so we respond to change in context
whether it's in my session as a user or
changes in in data there's lots of new
news articles that came out and we need
to respond and then the final one is
that it's manageable so it's often the
case that I don't just have one model in
production I have many and I have a team
of folks that are sharing infrastructure
and sharing production systems all of
these matter okay
so before we talk about responsiveness
let's talk about times when we go back
to this life cycle there's a few times
that matter and they often get conflated
so what's the first the first is the
time to respond we often call this a
requirement for latency or the latency
time so this is basically the time
associated when a user or a service
Cori's your predictive service and you
get a response back so that's one
important one another important one is
the time it takes to train a model at a
time it takes to train a pipeline this
relates to how quickly you can update
given new data another one that often
matters which most of us don't have a
good idea of how to quantify its how
long does it take my team to develop a
new model or a new feature and then get
into production there's many things that
matter there it's not necessarily a
systems constraint it's more of a how we
do data science and machine learning as
a business problem and then the final
one here is also related to being
adaptive if I have many models that are
running in production and and I let's
say that I have a model for me as a user
when I'm shopping for myself versus me
as a user when I'm shopping for my
mother and you can imagine if I'm on
Amazon I might be clicking on different
things and so based on different
features you could have a policy set up
that says when certain features are
detected you're gonna switch to the
model that says I am looking for a
present for my mother so so there's a
time associated with learning those
updates so each of these are different
and and they require different things in
your system to have those times be short
enough okay so how about addressing
latency how fast is fast enough for
queries so you have to ask the question
for what for queries so in the case of
online recommendations something like
Pandora
this is for a good experience so fast
enough for a good experience for ads
this is fast enough to score bid and win
the ad placement or for something like
credit card fraud this is fast enough
for the transactional decision so you
swipe on us on us square point-of-sale
thingy and there's a 30 millisecond
window to decide fraud or not fraud so
all of these have different timescales
associated with them so for online
recommendations for a good experience
this is basically fast enough so that it
doesn't seem slow as a human and that's
somewhere around 300 milliseconds unless
you're a super person and then for ads
this is faster somewhere around 60
milliseconds and then the most demanding
typically are in the financial services
sector okay
so different timescales matter for
different models and different
applications that you're building so
what's what's the challenge and scoring
fast so if I want to compute predictions
and less than something like 20
milliseconds so I can be good for all of
those applications for complex models
what matters or there's various things
that I care about complex models so this
this could be something like gradient
boosted trees and I want to make a
prediction on fraud or not fraud and
maybe I have many many factors involved
in my future vector this could be
queries this is a case for
recommendations so here it's typically
the case that I don't care about making
a relevant score for all items and users
in my library but just the ones that are
at the top so for me Shaun Skelly give
me a top k recommendations let's say of
the top hundred most likely things that
I'm gonna click on out of a library of
maybe millions I don't have to score for
all of those I just care about a fast
query to get those top K and then the
final one is for features so this could
be about fast currying of a set of
history or a set of contextual
information that's going
be relevant to input from my models and
then all of this you have to be fast
when I have not just one query but let's
say five thousand queries a second
because I have a really large-scale
service with many many users so we're in
the common solutions to low latency the
most fundamental is just faster faster
models so how do you get faster models
well you have really good
implementations that are written in
native code and native code scores
faster than interpreted code and so
that's one option the other option is
what might be called pre materialization
which is a big word which really just
means caching so this is about certain
queries that come up over and over again
if you cache those responses then you
don't have to actually have to call a
compute you just call a look up for
those queries so for us for faster
online model scoring we do this if you
attended rashad stock you heard about
our s frame and what we might do with
model chorong so our stuff is all in
native code it's all in C++ we have a
very very thin Python wrapper on top and
then that native code is optimized for
exactly these kinds of queries so that
when I have a low latency requirement I
can score fast s frame is built for that
but then the other is for fast querying
it's about how you implement the predict
function of your machine learning models
so that you're not predicting for all
things but only the things that matter
for that query the other case is for
caching so let's talk about that for a
second so smart materialization if you
think about so I'll ask the question to
you guys so if we if we think about
Amazon as a
what is a item that you think might be
good to cash here anyone from the
audience
trending items exactly so items that are
popular many many people are gonna be
clicking on them and so it's rarely the
case that you want to have a compute a
computation done for each new user that
comes and clicks on Harry Potter as an
example and so that's a case where if
you just have that answer stored you can
utilize that and it turns out in most
cases most queries it's sort of a
circular thing most things that are
popular are things that are queried Lots
and so for a small number of items if
you catch a small number of items you
can take care of a whole lot of your
load for the case of something like
recommendations where someone's clicking
on something so that's an application
that makes sense to use caching so other
applications where something like fraud
detection where each transaction vector
that comes in is going to be unique and
so in that case caching doesn't make
sense but for things like
recommendations where I have many many
users and a small set of items
relatively speaking this is super
important and then there's when you
build this in the right way it turns out
you get some other features for free so
in this case if I have a huge load of
folks or if I have a huge load coming
into my predictive service it often
makes sense to have a cache that's
shared across many nodes and so we call
that a distributed cache in our stuff we
use Redis as a distributed cache and and
what's great about this is basically if
one of the nodes in my cluster goes down
I have those answers stored across the
cache and so I get redundancy for free
so when we talk about heavy load coming
in this is
I guess I jumped ahead so let's say I
have something like that recommender
service I have tons of folks that are
all wanting to click on Harry Potter if
I just have one machine at a certain
load this service will slow down and the
queries will pile up and so the solution
to this is to do what's called scale out
and you can use something like an
elastic load balancer to handle traffic
routing to distribute those queries
across many machines and so this is one
of the basically the standard way that
anyone handles high-volume web services
but then what happens what are the other
things that I care about when I have
many nodes and high throughput I care
about what happens when some of these go
down and so then you want to do things
like be able to easily recover nodes
when they go down and that's about doing
things like storing state associated
with each of those nodes okay so that
that basically wraps up being responsive
and what you care about for being
responsive so you care a ton about fast
model querying but generally is going to
lead you to fast implementations of
certain models and you care about
caching for certain applications
okay what about adaptive so responsive
adaptive managable adaptive question is
to or for what so how fast do I need to
adapt let's start with a couple thought
experiments so let's say that I have a
recommender with tons of historic data
so this is a recommender with let's say
three years of data and I've trained
that up has a hundred million events
50,000 items and then this has been
running now for another X days and I
have 1 million new events tons of events
with the same 50,000 items is this is
this a case where I need to update
quickly soon I should I think about this
is it out-of-date am i screwing myself
by by not having the model update no no
because the deal is the data that I've
just added is just this tiny little blue
sliver of data if it's on the same
distributor distribution of items and if
in general I'm making the assumption
that the users are basically the same
nothing's changed in the world except I
have more of the same yeah probably the
model is not going to change a whole lot
if we take a look at a recommender
that's only using recent data this is a
very different example so maybe I've
trained a model using only yesterday's
events and now I have today's events
well now my new data matters a ton right
and and it's very likely that things
could have changed so this is a case
where I care about updating a lot well
here's another case where I care about
updating quickly so I have that same
historic data which has lots and lots
and I've gotten new data for the same
stuff and I've added a hundred new items
to my corpus to my library so in this
case for those hundred items things have
changed those hundred items I have no
data for before this and so it's going
to matter a ton to retrain or update my
model or change the strategy for how I
handle these new items so wend update
these are very simple examples but
they're useful to think about when we're
thinking about the different systems and
when to update them so when really
depends on ultimately my model
performance when is my note my model no
longer good enough so if I went back to
this example here the other thing that
would help guide me is tracking some
sort of online metric over time and if I
see that things are trending down that's
gonna be a good indication that we need
to do something so when is my model no
longer good enough when do I have a
better model so that's more about my
data science team and when do I have
something better to deploy but what we
just talked about is about basically
data velocity how much is my data
changing how much is the world changed
and and do I need to incorporate that
my model the other is just time
relevance so it could be the case that
we have an application that's
specifically about yesterday's news or
today's news in which case updating at
that time matters okay
this basically this is one piece of
being adaptive the other is thinking
about all of the things in the world or
my users experience that changes and how
they change at different rates and so if
I think about things like seasonality
what's happening in the markets these
are things that generally have pretty
long lifetimes and change on the order
of let's say months there's other things
that change faster going all the way
down to the case where within a session
I might be in a mode where I'm shopping
for a new shirt for myself but I also
want to buy a present for someone and so
how could I have a application that's
smart enough to recognize when I'm in
two different modes of search right and
in this case the timescale is more of
the order of minutes or so or wanting to
respond to our users so for the large
things or the slow-moving things
large things typically move slowly and
and so in this case you can typically
just rely on retraining your models
offline and and it's often the case that
I'll use a be testing to to look at
strategy a versus strategy B for things
that are more recent
this is smaller data smaller data
generally changes faster and this is the
case where we care about things like
online learning or using things like
bandits to assess how our models are
doing and dynamically change the
strategies that I'm serving so it's
totally reasonable that you could have a
strategy that adapts that based on my
real-time interactions figures out that
I'm no longer shopping for myself I'm
shopping for someone else
so when you think about that what
matters is feedback and there's some
funny things about feedback and machine
learning so we started off with cameras
and amazon.com and as it turns out
Amazon's been getting smarter about this
but you know I once looked at cameras
from then on for a long long time I was
only ever recommended basically other
cameras and other camera related stuff I
don't know how many cameras you have at
home but typically I only have one maybe
two at any given time and so what's
really important here is being able to
dynamically explore other things that
you don't have information about so this
is a for certain items this is a pretty
bad recommender right and so ultimately
when you're building machine learning
services you care about something like
trade-off between exploration and
exploitation and that's exactly what
multi-armed bandit Saar built for the
strategy is basically take some of your
some of your some of your quarries
you're gonna exploit you're gonna use
what you know works well in this case
this could be the recommender system
that's working well and giving the other
cameras and then the other percentage of
the time or percentage of slots that I'm
showing I'm going to show new things
that I don't have information about to
explore other interests that I might
have and you can get you can either be
really simple about that and do sort of
random exploration or you can be smart
about that and do things like show
maximal diversity in those other spaces
and that's that can be super super key
for things like online e-commerce this
matters a lot so what are some solutions
to the apptivity
for us it's all about time scale so the
question is how fast you need to update
your models so it's important to have
rapid
offline learning and that's about being
fast enough to keep up with how much the
data has changed so that's about running
model pipelines and deploying new models
streaming features we didn't talk about
this a lot of people talk about
streaming streaming do you do streaming
do you do streaming machine learning and
most people that are asking about that
they're trying to figure out what's that
actually mean how's that map to of the
applications that I want to build
because everyone's talking about
streaming in it so it must be important
where I see streaming fitting in is
really in features so in cases where as
an example we're in session behavior
what you want to do is have some sort of
aggregate of my behavior over a certain
time window and it's that aggregate that
you're changing that you're updating in
real time so that that can feed into
your model and then make a prediction
it's actually about the input data being
streaming rather than model training
being streaming another case here this
is used for fraud often where what
you're looking at is sort of what's what
are credit card transactions looking
like across our entire transaction
network over the last let's say 30,000
transactions and so you're accumulating
statistics that are basically a moving
window that you're then using in your
anomaly detection applications as a
feature so streaming features matter not
in the way that most folks talk about
them and then the last one we just
talked about is online bandits to to
adapt for things like in session
feedback and what's important there is
that you have a framework that's
flexible enough to basically implement
your own cost functions for how you're
gonna move between different models okay
manageable I'm not going to talk a ton
about this but you know manageability
for machine learning models is really
just about making it easy for your
systems and
your code to play well with others and
when you think about times when I've
build these things I used many different
things especially if you come if you
start off as a data scientist and you
you kind of pick up development skills
along the way your staff often starts
off looking like spaghetti and and
usually you have to spend a lot of time
with some production engineers to make
that production worthy at the end of the
day these systems tend to be pretty
complicated because we're using many
many different things all of which have
many different purposes they overlap and
that's hard to manage the other things
that you care about besides just
managing different systems and a code
base are things like providence and
reproducibility so for code we have
things like github for models you care
about things like sharing models knowing
when they were created having all of the
meta information describing what data
set was used for what model so that's
important being able to collaborate with
the production system is important
because usually it's not a team of one
that's that's building and deploying new
applications and then the final thing is
that things should just work such that
they continuously integrated so that's
about having a system set up that's
automatable Sofer for data we talked
about the intelligent application cycle
we have tools specifically for this
whole cycle GraphLab creates all about
building models and efficient training
of model pipelines you heard probably
lots of stuff from Rashad and Brian
about some of the cool things that are
there and then data predictive services
is all about serving models live has
services for some folks if you have to
go to ultra scale and that time to run a
model pipeline is taking too long
you can use distributed machine learning
we have some implementations of that
so this is my last little pitch for for
us if you're interested in building
applications with us this is kind of how
things map out so for predictive
services we have an architecture that
has a load balancer and a scale out
architecture we have model management
built in we have caching for those low
those repeated queries for low latency
or responsive so for things like boosted
decision trees were under ten
milliseconds for sort of reasonable
models super high throughput manageable
I didn't show it here but the other
thing that typically matters in a lot of
teams is being able to take I'll often
have a team that cares about deploying
they care about modeling and
scikit-learn
another team or team member that cares
about modeling in our so being able to
deploy both of those in one system is
key and and we've built things to
support that and then finally being able
to easily take those models and
integrate them into your other
applications through something like
restful api is crucial and we have all
that so if you're interested I didn't
have a demo today but grab us out in the
hall and we'll show you how to deploy
scikit-learn models with that I'm happy
to take any questions yeah
I made one big mistake which was when
describing this not reminding that
basically this deploys on your
infrastructure so we're not a cloud
service it's it's your machines running
our software but it's yours to manage
and deploy so we actually have no idea
what's going on with your data other
questions okay cool well come come grab
us outside and more than happy to talk
you